bill cosby as a stand-up comedian and
actor he became an american icon and
someone who millions of people looked to
as a father figure and a moral compass
he would disappoint the entire world
when they began to learn that he was not
at all the wonderful person that he
portrayed himself to be today on by
graphics we're going to talk about the
life of the career and the downfall Bill
Cosby William H Cosby jr. was born in
Philadelphia in 1937 and he was one of
four children his mother
Anna pearl was a maid and his father
William Henry Cosby senior was a steward
in the US Navy he was always the class
clown and never took his education very
seriously he had failed so many classes
that he decided to drop out of high
school in the tenth grade in order to
follow in his father's footsteps and
join the Navy he eventually earned a GED
through a military program he went to
Temple University in Philadelphia runs
an athletic scholarship to be on their
track and field team while in college he
worked part-time as a bartender and
would enjoy entertaining his customers
by telling jokes and making witty
comments his customers encouraged him to
get into stand-up comedy so he began
going to East Coast comedy clubs in
Philadelphia and New York City people
enjoyed his comedies so much that he was
able to book tours to the major cities
around the country he dropped out of
college when he was 20 years old in
favor of trying to make a career in
stand-up he appeared in several TV
series telling his jokes including The
Tonight Show in 1964 he married a woman
named Camille Hanks she was only 20
years old and in her sophomore year of
college at the time and Bill Cosby was
27 they met on a blind date and didn't
know each other that well before they
got married they went on to have five
children together during his stand-up
routines Cosby would talk a lot about
his kids and how difficult it was being
a father most parents could relate to
everything he was saying and it was
considered to be clean wholesome comedy
in 1965 Bill Cosby landed a starring
role on the TV show I Spy he became the
first african-american to star in a
network television show he was an
inspiration to people everywhere
young black men particularly looked up
to him as a role model however I spy was
seen almost as a one-hit wonder and
Cosby was not given any more of these
dashing roles in the future since he was
so popular with parents and he had
experience raising kids of his own
he turns one of his stand-up characters
Fat Albert into a cartoon series geared
towards young urban kids after making
some money from his career he went on to
finish his bachelor's and eventually
receive a master's degree and a PhD in
education from the University of
Massachusetts in the 1970s he used Fat
Albert as his thesis statement
explaining all the ways he used the
cartoon to educate children he put all
of this on his resume for creating
educational content for TV which helped
him land gigs on future shows like
picture pages The Electric Company and
more deep down Bill Cosby did not want
to continue making children's content
and he was really only doing it for the
paycheck he took a break from TV to come
out with comedy albums and they did
extremely well
he won six Grammy Awards and he was
suddenly thrust into the limelight as
being one of the best stand-up comedians
he would pride himself in writing clean
comedy that anyone could listen to and
he would often criticize other black
comedians like eddie murphy for using
obscenities
when he was 47 years old
Bill Cosby starred as a character named
dr. cliff Huxtable in The Cosby Show the
Huxtables had five kids just like Bill
Cosby and his real wife Camile people
assumed that this story was parallel to
who he was in real life it became so
popular the TV ratings showed that half
of the country was tuning in to watch at
that time black people were almost
exclusively portrayed negatively in the
media America witnessed criminal
activity ins controversial protests from
the black community this was the first
show to portray an upper-middle class
black family both parents they were
funny intelligence and hard-working
people who had an education a black
American was finally being seen in a
positive light and it was so genuinely
funny even white people watching it
helped to bring society together and it
helped them understand that really we're
all the same unbeknownst to the audience
none of this was ever Bill Cosby's idea
the show was created by two television
producers named Marcy Carsey and Tom
Werner they wanted to come up with a
concept for a sitcom that no one had
ever done before and after seeing Bill
Cosby stand-up they approached him about
doing a series Bill Cosby insisted that
he would not work for less than a
million dollars a year and the show
needed to have his name in the title he
wanted to make this TV show all about
him even though the producers already
knew what they wanted to do with the
series Bill Cosby tried to control the
narrative he pitched the idea that the
show should be about a taxi driver who
is tasked with taking care of the kids
he wanted to be married to a Latina
woman and he thought it would be funny
if she worked a traditionally male role
like a carpenter or a plumber
he chose a taxi driver for his character
because he wanted to be able to go on
monologues for the majority of episodes
in order to tell the jokes that he
normally told in his stand-up routines
the producers pushed back with Cosby
explaining their original vision for
portraying the new black American family
they eventually convinced him to give it
a try and it exploded into a cultural
phenomena however Bill Cosby received
all of the praise and recognition for
all of the positive changes that made in
society the show was filmed in New York
City and had attracted a lot of emerging
African American talent people loved a
Bill Cosby's character of cliff Huxtable
and most people believed that he was
just playing an exact
generated version of himself he was
giving black people acting jobs when
they had never had the opportunity to
work in the industry before as anything
more than a background character or an
extra he would have a parade of women
who had come to audition to be on The
Cosby Show people who worked with him
knew that he was constantly cheating on
his wife but they assumed that these
relationships were consensual a girl
would be seen speaking to Cosby she
would get one or two lines on the show
and then she was never seen again but no
one could have imagined how dark the
situation with Bill Cosby actually was
when the doors were closed in a lot of
ways The Cosby Show truly did
revolutionize the industry and no matter
who he was as a person there is no
denying that he was also the first
african-american to win an Emmy but for
fans of the show he was America's dad
people idolized him and he knew it he
wasn't afraid to take advantage of
people's trust and their respect to the
absolute fullest extent even though the
vast majority of the show was fiction
there were moments when Bill Cosby
incorporated stories from his real life
into The Cosby Show for example there
was his relationship with his son Ennis
who was the parallel to the character of
Theo he grew up getting bad grades in
school and Bill Cosby constantly called
his son lazy and told him that he wasn't
trying hard enough it was later revealed
that Dennis actually had dyslexia once
he was given a tutor to help him cope
with his disability he began to do much
better in school and went on to attend
Columbia University Teachers College
hoping to become a special education
teacher
Bill Cosby told the writers of the show
what it happens they used a parallel
storyline with the character of Theo the
characters playing Cosby's children they
all grew up and the show ended in 1992
in 1997 and this was on vacation in Los
Angeles driving at Mercedes his car got
a flat tire so he pulled over to the
side of the road in order to fix it in a
completely freak act of violence a young
white man who was high on drugs
attempted to rob Ennis and its reach for
his wallet but the man shot him in the
head when the paparazzi showed Arthur
Bill Cosby's house asking for a comment
about the death of his only son he
quietly said he was my hero and shut the
door
[Music]
after taking some time off to grieve
Bill Cosby returned to show business he
tried and failed to start more TV series
as well he came back in the public eye
after his famous jell-o commercials he
was having financial trouble and the
shows were no longer doing well in the
ratings
behind the scenes of the jello
commercials he scolded parents and
kicked children off the set if they were
not behaving well enough he would get
into arguments with business executives
about how to sell the product because he
thought he knew better than them he
would often ad-lib instead of following
the actual lines that had been given
despite being so difficult to work with
he was earning three million dollars a
year doing just these ads Bill Cosby
realized that the image of a perfect
father it was working and people loved
it so he decided that he wanted the
world to believe that he truly was this
great person he gave college
scholarships to african-american
students and participated in multiple
charities in his name however his true
colors would come out on set and
whenever he went on lecture tours he
spoke down to African Americans under
the guise of giving people tough love if
his words were spoken by a white person
they would be considered disgustingly
racist he was always very degrading
talking down to other black people as if
he was on this pedestal of some sort of
moral high-ground one of the most famous
examples of this is known as the
poundcake speech during this speech
given at the NAACP on the 50th
anniversary of Brown and Board of
Education Bill Cosby
blamed black parents for their
children's poor behavior and he went on
like 20 minute rants lecturing and
talking down to African Americans who
were living in poverty he said that if
it were not for their laziness and
irresponsibility then white people would
have more respect for African Americans
he said we are not Africans those people
are not Africans they don't know a
damned thing about Africa with names
naik Shaniqua allegra Mohammed's and all
that crap and all of them are in jail
they were so bad that in the transcripts
the NAACP had to add their own
commentary in parentheses after some of
Cosby's worst comments just so that
people would know that they disagree
with a lot of what he said some people
agreed with Bill Cosby then applauded
him others called him a race traitor in
2005 a sociologist and professor from
the University of Pennsylvania named
Mike
Eric Dyson wrote an entire book in
response called is Bill Cosby right or
has the black middle class lost its mind
Dyson breaks down points bunny points
just how wrong Bill Cosby is and how
truly difficult it is for African
Americans to overcome racial bias white
privilege and socio-economic
disadvantages it was never a secret that
Bill Cosby was cheating on his wife he
was often called a womanizer and openly
admitted in multiple interviews that he
had girlfriends outside of his marriage
once in every magazine he said when you
turned 40 you look at the enjoyment you
may get from a given activity and then
you look at the amount of work that may
have to go into it for example sex with
a young beautiful woman who has plenty
of energy a talented young actress named
Lily Bernard was mentoring under Bill
Cosby in the hopes that she could get a
part on the show she was honored that he
was taking the time to teach her about
acting he always told her that she was
one of his kids and she truly did see
him as a father she never had any
intentions of sleeping with him and
believed that everything was strictly
professional she became friends with the
other actors on set and everyone
believed that she would eventually
become a new character on the show when
Cosby for she was ready she finally got
the part in the TV show which was a
speaking role
Everts only lasted for a few seconds
after knowing her for a year Bill Cosby
convinced her to go to Atlantic City
with the promise that she would meet an
agent he was gonna help with her acting
career she had no reason not to trust
him after all she felt like Bill Cosby
was her dad when they got there he gave
her a drink and she blacked out she woke
up to him raping her on the floor it was
so surreal she couldn't believe it was
happening
she was in denial hoping that it was
just a bad dream when it was over and
reality sank in she told him that she
would go to the police
he threatened to sue her for defamation
and told her that she would go to jail
he also threatened to completely ruin
her acting career he told her you're
dead to me Bernard you hear me you're
dead lady Bernard was no longer allowed
on the set of The Cosby Show not only
did she lose her mentor and father
figure but she also lost all of her
friends that she got to see every day
the events was beyond traumatizing for
her she attempted to get a role
a few other TV shows but eventually gave
up on acting and decided to become an
artist even years after the rape Lily
Bernard was afraid to come forward
because she truly did believe that he
would make good on the promise to sue
her for defamation she was a struggling
actress in New York who could not pay
her rent let alone hire a lawyer she
also knew that if the idea of Bill Cosby
meant so much to her it would also crush
the hopes and dreams of African
Americans across the country she also
knew that no one would believe that now
it's important we out here this was just
one of many stories and we couldn't
possibly go over all of them in the
short video the total of 60 women came
forward with similar stories about Bill
Cosby andrea constand was the first
woman to come forward and publicly
accuse him of rape he offered to pay for
her college degree but she brought him
to court instead several journalists
wrote about the case but many people
brushed it off as a false accusation
people said that constant was just
trying to make money from Bill Cosby and
that he couldn't possibly be anything
but this perfect cliff huxtable guy that
the kids all grew up with despite all of
the proof being out there the issue was
not reignited to gain until 2014 a
stand-up comedian named Hannibal Buress
was gaining a lot of attention for his
role in the Comedy Central series broad
city during one of his stand-up shows he
called out Bill Cosby saying that he had
no right to lecture black people on
their bad behavior when he himself is a
rapist the story went viral suddenly
people knew and they actually listened
because it was another black man
confirming the truth soon after she went
public thirteen women approached Andrea
constant saying that they had also been
victims of rape by Bill Cosby
soon after the comments by Hannah Buress
went viral a reporter from The
Associated Press attempted to ask him
about the accusations during this
interview we can see firsthand out
Bill Cosby uses intimidation to make the
reporter back down from revealing his
comments on the rape accusations he
tells the reporter that if he wants to
have a serious career he will not show
the questions in their film he was seen
as so powerful that he was untouchable
[Music]
despite all of these accusations coming
forward in the media people truly could
not fathom that Bill Cosby was a rapist
many of his friends they came forward to
defend him including Whoopi Goldberg she
later recanted her statement the first
trial had a hung jury they could not
decide if he was guilty or not trials
are supposed to be unbiased and jurors
are not supposed to learn too much about
a defendant outside of the quorum but
decades have seen cliff Huxtable on The
Cosby Show on TV mints it was nearly
impossible for people to separate the
tune of matter how hard they tried they
just couldn't believe that this sweet
man was capable of such a horrible thing
Bill Cosby admitted more than once that
yes he gave quaaludes to women in order
to have sex with them but he didn't
define that as rape he had actually
admitted this in interviews with
magazines years before but after hearing
him say this so casually on the witness
stand
the jurors knew that he was truly guilty
even though 60 women have come forward
only three brought their claims to court
keep in mind that this doesn't mean the
rest are lying it just means that they
want to move on with their lives and not
have to retell the stories of the worst
moment in their life and have their
personal and family lives exposed in the
media in September of 2018 he was
convicted of aggravated indecent assault
and was sentenced to three to ten years
in prison at 81 years old it's very
likely that he will spend the rest of
his life behind bars so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do give us a thumbs up below
don't forget to subscribe got a
suggestion for us leave it in the
comments below and if you see when you
like upvote it the ones that come to the
top I'm most likely to see one thing
about making some of those so go ahead
and do that also if you leave us
something else to watch right now I've
got another channel called today I found
out you'll find that links to on the
screen now as well as below this video
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]